tis the season for getting sweet gifts  but there's that other side to the  holiday season and it's called giving  and guess what you don't have to wait  until winter to do so  it's called extra life play games to  help kids in need that's right it's that  time again to nestle up near a warm fire  or some hot cocoa and watch game slot 72  our extra live stream a Palooza we  stream games for three days straight  spanning across three countries raising  money for the UCSF Benny Hoff Children's  Hospital join the chat have some fun and  donate for the kids starting this Friday  November 9th til Sunday the 11th catch  us on gamespot.com youtube.com /  GameSpot or twitch.tv slash GameSpot  remember any little bit helps we'll see  you then  [Music]